[Music]
yeah it's just dad nothing's cool
nothing's cool with that anymore but
brad often takes things the kids make
and turns it into something like
he made a blanket one year of all their
drawings
the couple started the decade oh so in
love hitting red carpets together
gushing about their kids
brad even had to sport a cane after
putting his life on the line for
vivienne
i was carrying my daughter down a slope
and i slipped and it's me or her
i'm getting really annoyed with the
skein i think i got a couple more days
and i'm gonna
wing it he fights through it and
pretends he's uh he's not injured so
he's
nice work you know late now you go man i
really like the soda that's downstairs
it does work and you go get it that's
nice
2012 gave us the hashtag angie's right
leg after jolene
at the oscars it was also the year brad
popped the question proposing with this
reported one million dollar rock
and their six kids were already wedding
planning i've got a lot of crazy ideas
and i'm sure most of them will win out
so yes they'll they'll be the ones
deciding that
you know when it comes and how it's done
i'm sure three months after that
interview brangelina said
i do in france angie wore a versace
dress
the veil included sketches by their kids
i was married
[Music]
the couple skipped a honeymoon to go
shoot their second movie together by the
sea
written and directed by angelina the
drama about a marriage on the rocks was
a far cry from their first room together
mr and mrs smith
you're sick no you're sick you know we
came out stronger on the other end
just making something together and
something she wrote
was a real pleasure if you weeks into it
we wondered if it was a good idea
because it is quite it's heavy and it's
a lot of fighting it's pretty ugly
the film bombed at the box office making
only 3.3 million dollars
interbrad the producer he took a step
back from acting while fighting a bitter
custody battle with angie
by the end of 2016 brad was sober and
got his groove back
how does brad pitt relax just friends
family get outside
make some things i feel pretty
privileged and and
you know listen there's a shelf life on
this thing hopefully we have other
things going for us once upon a time in
hollywood was brad's first big screen
acting role since 2016's allied
he quickly followed it up with the drama
at astra what a year for you two
fabulous pieces of cinema will you be
done after this for the year are you
gonna relax get to put it away
yes and get on to other things but that
relaxation
had to wait award season had brad's name
all over it
in 2020 he made a clean sweep at all the
award shows
brad pitt delivering in speech after
speech
first at the globe i also have to thank
my partner in crime ldc
he's an all-star he's a gent and
i wouldn't be here without you man i
thank you
still i would have shared the raft
then the national board of review my
goals in life now are pretty simple
just to be happy stay healthy
and not get into a financial situation
where i have to do ocean's 14.
i got to add this to my tinder profile
let's be honest it was a difficult part
a guy who
gets high takes his shirt off and
doesn't get on with his wife
it's a big stretch brad won the sag
awards too but the honor may have been
eclipsed by this moment when brad
reunited with jen
backstage the world the internet
everyone is waiting they're hoping for
this moment where you and jennifer run
into each other so they can take their
picture
i'll run into jen she's a good friend
yeah so they can
you know you know how this goes the
second the second most
important reunion of her year exactly
you know how that works
on friends and then they were saying
that anyways
what do you make of all the
ridiculousness about you and
brad reuniting on all these carpets all
season long it's hysterical but what
else are they going to talk about
the whisper the hand-holding
those smiles and that wrist grab
like brad just didn't want to let go the
reunion was fast and only lasted a few
seconds
award season has been so fun even at the
baftas aka the british oscars which he
skipped to be with daughter zahara who
was recovering from surgery
he kept the laughs going by sending
co-star margot robbie to accept on his
behalf
and take a few jabs at mexico and he
says
that he is going to name this harry
because
he is really excited about bringing it
back to the states with him
his words not mine thanks but a week
later at the oscars
you have more jokes written for tonight
no i'm going all i'm going all like
downer tonight is my plan
brad pig brad was emotional reflective
this is for my kids who color everything
i do i adore you
thank you and full of gratitude once
upon a time in hollywood i think that's
the truth
you